when i tell you to think about the words
bravery
and one piece the chances are rather
high that a certain character just
appeared before your eyes
usopp but why is that i was thinking
about this
a lot when i was rereading the entire
story the other day
how is it that in a world which is
buzzing with brave characters
facing the most unthinkable situations
our mind
still moves to someone that often is
undeniably afraid
what makes usop a true symbol of bravery
for us
to answer this question we must first
understand what it actually means to be
brave
bravery is the admirable quality of
being able to confront frightening
things
and since everyone is afraid of
different things being brave means
something very different for every one
of us
to illustrate this imagine two very
different characters
a knight that is used to being on the
battlefield and
a small boy who's rather shy and has
difficulties making friends
clearly both of them have very different
fears
it might take bravery for the knight to
battle a dragon instead of regular
people
but it also takes bravery for the shy
child to walk into a new classroom and
meet new people
a very common misconception about
bravery is that being brave
equals not being afraid this is simply
not true though
brave people do feel fear but they're
able to manage and overcome this fear
so that it does not stop them from
taking action they have trained
themselves to
manage their emotional response to being
afraid and as a result they overcome
their fear
rather than the fear overcoming them you
could even say that in a way
one cannot be brave without being afraid
first
and i think it's important to understand
this since
usopp is often criticized for still
being a coward and being afraid in
certain situations
but as we now know this argument is not
really
valid in order to be brave you do not
have to lose your fear
but much rather learn how to manage and
overcome it
what we have to look for in usop's
development as a character then
is not whether he becomes less and less
afraid over time
but rather if he becomes more and more
able to deal with his anxieties
and that is exactly what we will do in
this video we will look
at the most important moments in usop's
character arc
and try to understand whether he truly
hasn't developed
at all over time or if he maybe is
closer to his dream
than we all tend to think we first get
to
meet usob in syrup village back in the
east blue
he's a cowardly and chronically lying
young man that struggles growing up
without his parents
while the villagers all blame usop for
this behavior
apparently none of them had the idea to
take the orphan boy in and give him the
love and attention he clearly is looking
for
maybe this was due to his father being a
pirate but
still this is no real excuse to abandon
a lonely child in my mind
as a matter of fact usab started his
behavior of lying in the first place
when he started yelling to his sick
mother that pirates were coming
hoping that the thought of a husband
returning home would strengthen her
spirits enough to keep her alive
it is truly astonishing then that
despite his understandable lack of
confidence and need for attention
usopp still grew up to be a
compassionate extroverted and
selfless man based on his backstory i
would say that we have
a relatively good idea as to why usopp
turned out to be such a cowardly and
anxious person
when he first encounters luffy and zorro
in other words the starting point for
usop's character arc is a lying coward
whose insecurity and deep lack of
self-confidence
are rooted in a lack of love and
attention that he received while growing
up
in essence similar to all the other
straw hats usopp's character arc
consists of two major parts
his relationship with luffy and his
dream especially in usop's case though
these two themes are
very closely interconnected as we will
see over the course of his journey
usop's relationship with luffy starts
off as a mix of admiration
friendship and defiance luffy saves us
village from the evil captain kuro who
was trying to kill his dear childhood
friend kaya for her family's fortune
usop admires luffy for his strength and
decides to set out to see with him to
become a pirate
just like his father the friendship he
develops with luffy
is different from the other straw hats
though both
are two young men around the same age
with similar interests and a similar
sort of humor
while this friendship plays an important
role in creating the early dynamic of
the crew
it also causes usopp to continuously
underestimate luffy's authority as a
captain
especially in the early days of the crew
we often see him trying to compete with
luffy over the role of captain
this is the starting point of usual's
relationship with luffy
in comparison usopp doesn't find his
dream and ambition
until the events at arlon park only when
one of arlon's fishman
chu is shooting water bullets at usopp
who's hiding behind a tree
does he realize that he actually wants
to truly help his friends
in this moment he decides to become a
brave warrior of the sea
in other words usopp dreams of
overcoming his fear and insecurity
in this moment for the very first time
he then goes on to overcome his
cowardness and actually manages to
outwit
and defeat the fishermen all by himself
this dream that usop now has found for
himself
is further cemented on little garden
after entering the grand line where he
meets the two giants
dory and brogi after learning about
their everlasting battle on the island
usopp takes the giants of elbaf as a
role model for his ambitions
a theme that reappears throughout the
entire series
the next big obstacle he has to overcome
is in alabaster
where together with chopper he has to
fight mr four
and miss merry christmas for the first
time usob's loyalty towards luffy is put
to a real test
usopp races to the challenge though and
that in a fight where he even takes a
hammer to the head
nonetheless usop overcomes his pain
proclaims luffy as
the future pirate king and ultimately
manages to defeat the two agents
together with chopper
battles like this continue to progress
usop's dream to become a brave warrior
of the sea
but in every arc his insecurity about
his role in the crew
grows worse slowly but steadily the
reader already starts to get a feeling
that these negative emotions
might end up in disaster what follows
next is
one of the two decisive turning points
in usop's character development
the water 7 and any sloppy arc marked a
low
and at the same time turning point for
usopp after the straw hats learned that
the going mary won't be able to continue
her journey due to the irreparable
damage he has suffered
luffy decides to leave the ship behind
this is
a breaking point for usopp for several
reasons
obviously the mary was a fond memory of
his village and his friends
but of course it goes much deeper than
this
usop's feeling that he doesn't have a
role in the crew has slowly been
building up in him over time
even though sanji calls him the straw
head sniper in alabaster
usop is not able to identify with this
position yet
in the merry he sees a crew member that
has grown too weak
and as a result was abandoned by the
crew not only does he see himself as one
of the weakest member on the ship but he
also doesn't feel like he has any other
purpose to fulfill
like nami or chopadoo as a result usop
is afraid of being left behind by his
comrades just like the mary was
and luffy even goes so far as to tell
him that he's not a shipwright after he
unsuccessfully tries to fight for the
mary's remain
usop then goes on to openly confront
luffy with his anxiety
you can't just cut off those members
that are useless there's
no way i could catch up to any of you
monsters you don't need any weak members
right luffy this anxiety of not being
good enough and being left behind
combined with his lack of respect for
luffy's position culminate in his
decision to leave the crew
and ultimately fight luffy for the
ownership of the mary
this marks an absolute low point in
usop's story arc
not only was he unable to act according
to his dream but
he also broke his ties with luffy which
removed him from the crew on an
ideological level as well
after instantly regretting his decision
to break up with the crew
usopp creates the character of soga king
for himself
he is a representation of everything
usop wants to be
and at this point in the story serves as
a source of courage for him
hiding behind a mask gives him the
opportunity to fight beside his forsaken
friends and gives him a feeling of
security during the battle on in his
lobby
later after almost being killed by jabra
sanji saves usop and tells him
do what only you can do finally
usopp accepts and establishes his role
and purpose in the crew and
starts sniping toward the gates of
justice to protect robin
when the crew is about to leave him
behind back at water 7
he finally demonstrates bravery and
manages to overcome
his fear of being left behind and not
fitting in he shouts his apologies to
luffy and the crew
and fully accepts luffy as the captain
this
entire arc of redemption was of great
importance to the development of usopp
in regard to both his dream
and his relationship with luffy usop now
has officially rejoined the crew
after an incredible 106 chapters of
absence
our next stop is thriller bark where
usob once again has to rely on soggy
king
in order to fight perona it is the first
situation though in which he's the only
one capable of defeating an enemy
this time he has to overcome his anxiety
to fight for the sake of the entire crew
later after the events of marineford
usopp desperately tries to get back to
luffy
saying that if he can not comfort his
captain in times like this
he could not really call himself a true
straw hat this
shows us that his acceptance and
relationship with luffy has
now gone full circle over the course of
the two years usop then tries to get as
strong as he can for his captain
and aims to become a true sniper worthy
of fighting for the future pirate king
the last arc that we have to take a look
at in order to understand usop's
character development is dressrosa
this is the second major turning point
for usopp in the story so far
when stuck in the underground harbor
robin gets turned into a toy
leaving usop as the last remaining straw
hat to stand against treble
and sugar the tontara who are being
wiped out by treble
put all their hopes into solando another
character created by usopp to hide
behind
this puts immense stress on usopp that
has been building up for the majority of
the arc
finally he can't handle it anymore and
same as he did in orlon park
he runs away in order to hide tragically
right here usa represents one of the
main themes of dressrosa
deception all this time doflamingo had
been deceiving the tontata
and now they have to find out that usual
was essentially doing the same
yet same as he did at arlong park ustop
realizes that this is not who he really
wants to
be he comes out and tells the tontada
the truth
he is usopp the sniper of the straw hat
pirates
and he will be their hero in this moment
having neither soga king nor usolando
left to hide behind he finally overcomes
another one of his great insecurities
and
stands against treble and sugar as
himself
he no longer needs a mask to hide behind
he then successfully saves the tontata
and even manages to knock out sugar
twice
this newly found courage and
self-confidence are almost directly
rewarded by the awakening of his
observation haki
that he then uses to save luffy and law
finally he was also able to prove his
worth for luffy
not to the others but to himself and
confirm for himself
his right for being part of the crew